من كان يتخيل يوما ان ياتي الى باريس
لاستكشاف انواع العطور او حتى الاستمتاع
بسحر الابنيه والشوارع ليجد نفسه محاصرا
وسط اكوام من القمامه ورائحه كريهه اصحاب
المطاعم والعمال هؤلاء يقومون بازاله
القمامه من امام مطاعمهم لانها اثرت على
اعمالهم بشده بيروت ما كانت هيك يعني
باياماتها
يعني ما بعرف شو بدي اقول
الزباله والروائح اللي بتطلع كيف العالم
بدها تيجي تاكل بس
والله كنا عايشين بيروت احسن
وهيدي كومه الزباله شلناها
اصحاب المطاعم قرروا التحرك بمفردهم على
امل ان تقوم البلديه بازاله اكوام القمامه
هذه العمليه ستتواصل طوال فتره ما بعد
الظهر سنقوم برش ماء الجافيل والتنظيف
بانتظار ان تاتي بلديه باريس وتاخذ كل هذه
القمامه اتمنى ان ينتهي هذا الاضطراب لكن
هذه المبادره لم ترق لبعض السكان الذين
اعتبروا انها لا تحل المشكله بل تقذفها
امام بيوت اناس اخرين لا ذنبلهم بما يحصل
هذا ليس امرا مقبولا ان تقوم المطاعم بنقل
نفاياتها امام ابنيه السكان انا ايضا لدي
قمامه لكن لن اقوم بالقائها امام مباني
الاخرين لاتخلص منها
الاضراب الذي دخل يومه السابع خلف حتى
الان اكثر من خمسه الاف طن من القمامه في
باريس وجعل هذه الاقوام غذاء للقوارض
والحشرات هذا المشهد لن ينتهي قريبا مع
استمرار عمال النظافه باضرابهم ما دفع
نائب رئيس كتله الاكثريه النيابيه في
البرلمان الى التحذير من انه في غضون ايام
قليله ستكون مدينه النور باريس مغطاه
بالكامل بالنفايات